whoa today we're playing king of the
table the winner stays on table first 11
points wins a special rule if you win
three points in a row let's go
okay two same colors start yeah and you
start okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I could say that's there's nothing
enough room here are you sure you don't
want to come on this side I think I
think I'm good thanks okay I need to get
my first points
[Music]
oh the folder where did that come from
never plays off this back
[Music]
no my own my own
[Music]
yeah that's what my third in a row
special only for him because your
backhand is so overpowered
[Music]
you saw that footwork yeah why not the
hospital what we can do
[Music]
[Music]
well that was my sixth in a row should
there be like another special rule you
had double special rule right hand and
only for hand there's no test I'm gonna
win this point I have to go for it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Arden
[Music]
okay
don't give me there it feels like I've
said that before don't give me there
don't give me there that's the biggest
mistake you can make
[Music]
[Applause]
there's nothing you can do
[Music]
hello
[Music]
nothing with the story points
[Music]
yes now that I deserve
I deserve that one
[Music]
[Music]
who's that look match point match point
hi oh nice area
another match points I also needed one
probably yeah
so today the king of the table was the
sensation thanks anyway remember to
subscribe to our channel here and what
sharp previous videos there until next
time